it's come to my attention that some
people are questioning the validity of
yomi Park's story yeah the audacity this
is
this is crazy Saloon
on Earth could you question whether a
woman ate rats to survive as a child
how on Earth could you question whether
a woman's mother was sold to a [__]
farmer in China
how on Earth could you question whether
these things are real like what do you
think happened do you think that like a
right wing Think Tank might have saw her
story and used her as a pawn to get out
their ideas with zero screw ending no
that's insane what do you want to say
about you only poor friend of the shower
that's the heavy Queen
got your [__] mouth absolutely
everything about her is real bro
everything
that's what I'm saying you've got to be
crazy what do these guys say it takes a
lot of balls dude it takes a lot of
audacity yeah pushing This Woman's story
[__] Libs bro dude
what about it he might be the one
planting the seeds he might be the one
pushing the story oh that's yeah it's
not real he's like oh she didn't Escape
yeah she's from Massachusetts
North Korea propaganda make it make it
make sense to me because I'm I'm missing
because he's gonna feel bad he's gotta
he's gotta find a PR battle because
North Korea is looking bad so he's like
you know what her story's fake boom and
the first people to buy up the North
Korean propaganda are always the libs
always lives
they should go to North Korea they love
it yes they do man they should go there
bro I can't believe that they would
question the 100 accuracy of her story I
a little bit of wiggle room and any of
the things that she's ever said like
when she said that they have to push the
trains to make them go
trains go of course you're going to have
malnourished North Korean children
pushing a gigantic [__] train yes to
make it move of course right there's no
other way it could happen yes right or
wrong I've never been to North Korea
dude I don't know I assume people are
getting executed in the streets it makes
more sense yeah India could use that so
we get off the top of that [__]
you know what I mean less death risk if
you guys were pushing it instead of
[__] on top of it that would be 100
that would be way better that would be
way better safer 100 yeah all I'm trying
to say is nobody would question that
about India nobody but these [__]
lips man these
[Music]
what are they going to do next say
slavery wasn't that bad yeah right are
they gonna like read Harriet Beecher
Stowe's Uncle Tom's Cabin and be like
hey this isn't what it was like this is
an exaggerated version yeah it is I mean
nobody in history would do that right
nobody in history when Uncle Tom's Cabin
came out was like Harriet's exaggerating
why don't we interview some slaves and
see what they say yeah that never
I believe you I don't know but I believe
you corsic never happens we gotta start
a think tank dude think tanks are far
yes and then higher what
anyone right like
refugees that match up with our deals
yes who would do that but it's a good
idea it is we should do that for
something and why would they take the
money because they have no opportunity
education or ability to do anything in
life and maybe they just need to survive
that's a possible reason why they might
take it I doubt it but it's probably not
if we were to do it I bet you we could
we could find a couple that promote the
podcast through them or something break
the whole thing down
to silence someone came from like a
third world country right there's like
they're fleeing some type of War there's
some kind of poverty they get over here
somehow unbelievable conditions yeah
that they came from yeah exactly yeah we
hire think tank of us okay okay and we
get as many refugees as we can and we
basically tell them hey promote our
podcast anytime someone brings it up to
you like hey what do you love just be
like playground I love it and then
nobody can ever question them because
they came from such a horrible situation
exactly people are like oh my God that
broadcast is so offensive uh they'll be
like how dare you tell me what offensive
is yeah I come from a place where people
are really offensive yeah
the number one podcast of refugees oh my
God that's a [__] you're saying that
people might have done this no I'm
saying no one's done it we're the first
this is an original idea everybody
I truly have no clue I think aliens I
got lost and came back
got lost together I don't know if we're
the good guys or the bad guys but I know
the limbs are bad yeah yeah
I'm back right okay yeah everybody
[__] lips dude we gotta own those
lips dude want to react to this
react to that get triggered by that oh
my God there's some triggered they're so
triggered all the time dude thank God
we're never triggered by anything except
the things that trigger us and those are
okay to be triggered those are okay to
be triggered I mean [__] God said so
yeah or whoever else not to santis yes
because God and Ron DeSantis Ron can't
cheers a beer
I haven't seen this yet I'm excited it's
unbelievable why can't you Libs get one
[__] person that says charismatic As
Trump that's all everybody wants is a
charismatic liberal that's it so yeah
over the world if you had a liberal that
would take shots like this at one in the
morning on Instagram literally last
night Trump's Instagram page you need
the volume one in the morning
doesn't belong can you
tipping oh my god really by the time I
finish this song watch this watch this
watch this button
I mean just post it no cap just one
caption awkward and it just keeps it
moving man that's it crushed him
even though I do this constantly through
I'm rubbing my nose throughout the
podcast but that's not presidential no
it's not true